if anyone who's involved in science
to say you should never change your mind
doesn't understand what science is well
dr fauci thank you so much for joining
us
on the youtube channel again it's been a
year since you and i have spoken
we're doing it now in person without
masks on
right thanks to the vaccine how amazing
is that indeed
it's really one i think that one of the
most important
contributions in biomedical research to
so quickly
and effectively get a vaccine that
right now is performing in the real
world even better than it did in the
clinical trials so you feel more
confident in the vaccine
now than perhaps you did in december
2020. oh yeah
and the reason the reason is that um
in december 2020 we had the results
of the clinical trials which were very
impressive you know 94
95 but often is the case
is that when you get into the real world
of how the vaccine performs
outside of the pristine conditions of
the clinical trials
it doesn't usually look as good as it
looks in the clinical trials
on the contrary we're seeing the
opposite now we're seeing that when you
get data not only from the united states
i mean when i say data
i'm talking about hundreds of thousands
of people being followed up
in prospective cohort studies the data
are at least
as good if not even better not only
against
what we call the wild-type virus namely
the one that's
the standard one but when variants
appear
the vaccine seems to do quite well
against them also so it really is
very good news with regard to vaccines
in this year
how do you feel where we are in our
current battle with the pandemic
overall i think it's very positive but
one of the things that we get concerned
about
is declaring victory prematurely
because even though if you look at all
of the parameters
particularly most recently over the last
month or two is that the seven day
average
of daily cases continues to come down
and down one of the issues with that is
if we see the numbers go
down and people say well then why should
i get vaccinated
everything seems to be going well that's
a mistake
if you don't really get the level down
very very low
there's always the concern and the real
concern not just theoretical that you
could start getting more infections
at least in this country we're in a very
uh fortunate situation that we have
enough
vaccines to vaccinate everybody
when you look at other countries where
they're
literally and figuratively dying to get
vaccinated because they don't have
enough vaccines i mean take india has
two to three percent
of their population is fully vaccinated
and about
11 to 12 percent have received at least
one dose
i mean that is not good absolutely and
i've heard you say numbers
uh 70 to 80 percent might be a target
that we're looking for for individuals
to be vaccinated
in order to reach this level of herd
immunity uh are you
still comfortable you know one of the
things we want to re-emphasize because
people
say well you're changing we're not
changing any numbers we don't know
what the threshold of herd immunity is
yeah we know what it is for measles
um we're estimating that it's somewhere
between 70 and 85 percent
for um soros kobe 2 we don't know for
sure
when you don't know for sure the thing
to do is just forge ahead
over the yeah just get as many people
vaccinated as you possibly can
and when you get that level of
protection that turns out
to be the threshold of hurt immunity
you'll know it
because you'll see the infections is
almost disappear when you get it to that
level
where do or where does natural immunity
play into this because the last time you
and i spoke one of the major questions
we were answering granted it was april
2020 at the time
was that we believed and i think we
still believe that reinfection is very
rare
yes it is where do those individuals
fall on that 70 80
spectrum do we factor them in into that
number well we're talking about
vaccines now when we talk about the
president's goal
if you're talking about this somewhat
elusive
term of threshold of hurt immunity
you put them all in the same bucket
because if you have someone who's been
infected
recovered has a good immune response
that person can be protected for a
considerable period of time
we still don't know i mean people ask
how could you not know
the reason we don't know is because
we've only been doing this for
about a year or more you know i mean the
whole thing has been about 16 months but
the vaccine plus infected
people we don't know we hope it's
considerably longer than
six years a year the companies have said
well you're probably going to need
we don't know what's going to be a year
exactly i've seen no evidence to show
that we need
a booster exactly yeah the pfizer ceo
you think that's a business decision
more than well
i think what they want to do is they
want to be prepared and that's the
reason why and that's the reason why
we the federal government in
collaboration with industry
are actually doing trials to give boosts
to people from the original clinical
trials
to determine how high up you get their
response
how long it lasts so we're anticipating
the possibility maybe the likelihood but
certainly the possibility
of needing to boost people at some time
or other both for the durability of the
response
but also to get maybe a
variant specific boost however the good
news about that as i mentioned a little
bit ago
is that many of the variants
particularly the dominant one for us
right now is b117
the vaccine works extremely well a
number of studies now have looked at
what it does to some of the other
variants and although it diminishes
your effectiveness a bit it's still well
within the realm of some reasonably good
protection
because ultimately our goal at least the
way i view it
with the covet 19 vaccination is really
to target severe illness
hospitalizations and deaths
because if we can control those numbers
turning it into
a perhaps less lethal virus more like
the flu right
it becomes more manageable is that sort
of no absolutely and see and that's one
of the things that we're working with
now trying to get a good handle
on what the right approach would be
with the variance because we are going
to continue to see variance
until the rest of the world is
essentially well controlled which it
won't be for a couple of years
even if we push to get people back we
want to get
the rest of the world vaccinated as
quickly as possible and i believe we
have you know a moral responsibility to
do that not only because
we're a country that has resources but
other
of the rich country should do that but
it's also in our own self-interest
because when you have a lot of dynamics
of viral replication
in whatever country in the world it will
generate variance and when it does
sooner related because of the
interconnectivity in the world
we're going to see variants here but
one of the things that we're we really
want to nail down but it looks
as i mentioned it looks pretty good that
if you get a high level of immunity
against the original
virus it does spill over to protection
against several of the variants
for individuals who are vaccine hesitant
they've seen cdc guidelines change
a lot of times rightfully so because the
evidence evolved and we needed to make
different recommendations
what do you say to those individuals who
are vaccine hesitant right now well
first of all you don't want to be
pointing a finger at them or making them
feel guilty you want to try and explain
to them
why it's important for them to get
vaccinated by giving them
two things giving them all the facts
that they need to answer any questions
that they have
was it too quick no we have an answer to
that
that's it's the culmination of decades
of research that got us there
wasn't the 11 months from january to
december
then they ask well did you test it
enough i want to wait and see well
hundreds of millions of people have
gotten the vaccine now so we're past the
time of
let's wait and see the other thing is to
make it
extraordinarily easy for somebody to get
vaccinated because there sometimes
is a combination of hesitancy and what
they consider inconvenience
remember back early on people were
trying to negotiate computers and
getting an appointment and this 1a group
1b
1c that's that's gone now right now the
way it is
it's extraordinarily easy to get
a vaccine you got 40 000 pharmacies that
can do it you have
pharmacies where you don't even need to
call up or make an appointment just walk
in and say i want to get vaccinated
you have community vaccine centers you
have mobile units
it's very easy to get vaccinated right
now yeah i work
a lot with senate majority leader chuck
schumer in
pushing out some of the information
about the vaccine to help individuals
who are perhaps vaccine hesitant
or just want more information on the
subject
they're also asking a repeated question
about vaccinations and their children
you know pfizer has the approval at
least the eua for 12 and up now
what do you say to someone who's vaccine
hesitant for their children when they're
saying well you know children seem to
experience
a milder case perhaps of covid19 they're
not
perhaps spreading it as often should
children be vaccinated
yeah i mean there's no doubt it's the
chain of transmission
and even though children
statistically don't get as serious
disease
they can they can and if you look at the
hospitalizations that's absolutely
correct
very low for the children it gets more
and more and more as you go up for the
elderly
but if you look now today where
the overwhelming majority of the elderly
are protected
uh i mean we now s we have you know
about 80 of the elderly of at least one
dose so i mean
that's pretty good and the
hospitalizations and deaths among the
elderly
dramatically diminished then you're
starting to see well you know
young people do get infected and some of
them do get sick
so it's again the health of the person
even if you get mild disease
kids young young people get long covered
there's no doubt
that persistence of that really
sometimes almost incapacitating symptoms
of fatigue and muscle ache and
temperature dysregulation things like
that
and then there's the chain of
transmission that
you know you'll see papers that say kids
don't transmit
much kids can transmit it anybody that
says that they don't
they're not looking at reality they may
at certain levels
not transmit it as efficiently as the
crowding that you get as you get older
and the kind of things that people do
indoors
but it is part of the chain of
transmission if you are vaccinated
whether you're 50 years old 20 years old
65 years old
what can you feel comfortable doing once
you are vaccinated again there's a
variability
i think people who are significantly
immunosuppressed transplant
patients people who are on
immunosuppressive therapy
they may want to be a little bit more
careful with regard to masks but
the general average person who is
vaccinated can for their own safety do
almost anything
i mean indoors or outdoors the question
is when you're
when you're in a mixed environment
where you're in an establishment there
are people who are vaccinated people who
are not
that people who might be infected that
might be infecting others
there's the question of what is the
establishment going to do are they going
to say
if you want to come into my whatever the
establishment is it could be a college
you know it could be a workplace that
person has the
almost the right if you want to say to
say if you want to do that you got to
wear a mask
which then will have the vaccinated
person will say well
wait a minute i'm vaccinated what do i
got to wear a mask
and that's where the confusion comes in
which they're trying to sort out
once everyone is vaccinated or the 70 80
percent numbers
are hit for herd immunity what happens
does covet 19 go away
well it certainly will go to a level
that would no longer be
a public health hazard as it were
in this country but again it's a global
pandemic
and we do require a global response what
level do you think that we should start
saying
you know our supply is bigger than
demand here we need to start taking our
supply and sharing it with the world
we're going to do it
by the end of june beginning of july
we're going to be giving out 80 million
doses
for a starter yeah just for a starter
and there's more coming after that
as far as our handling of the pandemic
as a nation
as a scientific community if you could
change one thing or make an improvement
on one thing on our response so far what
would it be
well to me as i've said often it's that
there's
been an extraordinary amount of
divisiveness
in this country that's the worst
possible thing
i mean there's differences of opinion
but the
the the intensity of the divisiveness
has in so many respects and and one
can't deny it
the politization of a public health
approach
i mean when someone does or does not
want to do things like wear a mass
congregate setting
for reasons that that are not they don't
make public health sense they're more
ideological than they are public health
so if we were going to do something
different
we could say there's differences of
opinion there's differences of ideology
fine but when you're facing a public
health
challenge of this magnitude why don't we
put that aside for a minute
take care of the pandemic then you can
go back to ideological differences
we're talking about masking right now
with
the pandemic and the public health
setting i've heard you say in an
interview before that
masking can potentially continue past
the pandemic
what role do you that was taken
completely out of context by people
like to gotcha yeah you know no what i
was saying
i was air let me thank you let me
clarify this
i was asked people were saying you know
it's interesting in australia
during their flu season they had almost
no flu
they called us up and said wow we think
that's
due to the fact that we were wearing
masks
we were avoiding congregate settings in
order to prevent
the spread of cover 19
and we had a secondary effect that we
almost had no flu or other respiratory
illnesses
rsv para influenza
we had almost nothing then our winter
came
and we noticed the same thing that
wearing masks avoiding congregate
settings etc etc
so i was asked in an interview that do
you think that
some people might elect elect
might elect that they might want to wear
a mask during the winter season
to avoid flu or other respiratory
illnesses and i said you know
it seems reasonable if some people feel
that they want that extra protection
they could do it i
it's not going to be mandated my
question is more so
not for that gotcha purpose but in terms
of protecting yourself using a mask
you know in march of 2020 april 2020
even on my own youtube channel as a
family medicine doctor
i was urging people to not rush to buy
masks at that time
because the information we had at the
time wasn't focused on
asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic spread
there were shortages of ppe like i was
seeing patients in march
with no masks not because of uh
inadequate ppe but
because we didn't think that was
mandatory so yes and that's what i was
saying then
and then when we found out three things
i mean thank you for bringing that up
because that's when
i get accused by people who want to do
the gotcha that are flip-flopping
there's no flip-flop
back then there were three things a we
were told
that there was a shortage of ppe and
masks and we felt you know we don't want
to take it away from
others secondly there were no data
meta-analysis at the time that masks
were effective
outside of the hospital setting and then
three importantly we didn't fully
realize how
pervasive asymptomatic spread was
so what changed a it was clear there was
no
shortage of masks cloth masks work
meta-analysis showed
that in fact even outside of the
hospital settings
mass work and third we were hit with the
realization
that anywhere from 50 to 60 percent of
transmissions
occur from asymptomatic people that's
the reason why
we went from saying you don't really
need to wear a mask to you should really
wear a mask
that's not flip-flopping that's taking
evolution of data
and then making your recommendations
based on the data yeah in fact if we
didn't make that adjustment that would
be worse
for us because then we're not looking at
the data and evolving with the science
well anyone who's involved in science
to say you should never
change your mind doesn't understand what
science is
you've become a champion of science on
social media
you've become a meme uh your face has
been put on
t-shirts socks cupcakes i've seen
everybody celebrate the work that you've
done leading the way with humility with
honesty
uh treating science as it deserves to be
treated
how does that feel well i focus on what
i'm doing and not
bask in that because that's balanced by
the other side of people who attack
who are not science related who
are anti-science who it comes from
everything from
you know verbal attacks to ad hominem
nonsense to threats to my life and my
family
so it's balanced how does that
negativity affect you that's got to be
hard i mean as scientific communicators
i mean if you look over the course of
history scientific communicators weren't
really
celebrated researchers were almost
frowned upon when they would spend a lot
of time in media
how do you balance that no i mean right
now you have to communicate because
there's an
absolute need on the public to know and
understand the truth
this is something that's threatening
their lives their family the economy
when you politicize that when you have
take it out of the realm of public
health
and make it become almost a political
statement that's very damaging to the
overall
effort and the other thing is that if
you want to really
get into and understand the evolving
science
you've got to realize that things change
and you've got to be humble enough and
flexible enough
that when you get new data that you then
change
what you're doing based on the data
if you say i really want to never change
because if you change your flip-flopping
then you're back here and and you don't
take advantage
of the new data that every week every
month comes by
that's the thing that some people don't
seem to understand
well it's like the idea that scientists
can be wrong
and that's part of being a scientist
testing a hypothesis but science itself
is a process that can never be wrong
well
as as we've learned in medical school
when you
do these kinds of things that the
mentors always told us that
science by definition is self-correcting
you said that beautifully
um i want to read to you a statement
that one of my colleagues shared with me
late last night when i mentioned to them
that i was going to be interviewing you
she's a cardiologist on the west coast
and i want
just to read this to you to highlight
the impact that you've had on
individuals that perhaps you may not
come across in your everyday life i got
redeployed to a covet unit for my last
three months of my cardiology fellowship
i went to work every day before we had
adequate ppe
and i was putting people my age on ecmo
daily
i was constantly worried i was going to
die i was so scared
but i would come home from work and see
dr fauci on television
and he honestly made me less scared
hearing that how do you feel well that
obviously makes you feel good
i mean because that's what you that's
what i do that's what my job is
i'm a physician i'm a scientist trying
to get
as accurate information out to people
so if i can make a cardiology fellow
feel good
that makes me feel good you've been
doing this for a while you've served
under
many presidents you've worked with
administrations
of left right in between
is this the highlight we're still in the
middle of it i'll tell you that
when it's over we're still in the middle
of it we still have a way to go
it looks like we're going to nail it i
think we are
science will come to the rescue um
but yeah i believe we're going to get
out of this this is going to end
and it's going to end and hopefully
we'll be learn a good lesson
and be better off for it for sure so
everyone at home get vaccinated that's
the goal
we need to get everyone vaccinated so
that we don't have to play the game of
who's vaccinated who's not
and on a final lighthearted note in 2015
uh people magazine named me sexiest
doctor live it's kind of the joke of how
i got started on social media
and i use that as an opportunity to go
on television talk about primary care
prevention vaccinations since then they
haven't given the title to anybody else
in fact before me it was dr sanjay gupta
right
how would you feel about me passing on
that title to you
this year no thank you you're definitely
more sexy
you can you can keep it i'm 80 years old
that's enough i just think that would be
a great combination you've done all this
amazing work
you've kept people like my friend dr
ballardo calm during a very stressful
state
you've given us the best information
with the most humble approach but i
think it would be a funny top
story so maybe we could get people
magazine to throw you on for
2021 let's let's get this over with
first
thank you so much for your time dr fauci
for all of your work
seriously everyone from the medical
community my hospital atlantic health
system
uh senator schumer everyone we've been
working with so tirelessly to get people
vaccinated and you're leading the charge
on that so thank you
thank you thank you for being here